you know I always see this too
especially with some of my friends who
are on Instagram and they are bigger
right we were all big and consistently I
always see on their post they go I love
the way they look I love the way that I
am you know if you really did write and
I know these people too because they
struggled with their weight a lot and
they're always constantly trying to lose
weight and they're like I'm perfectly
beautiful nobody said that you [ __ ]
weren't nobody none of our friends like
you you clearly don't have like a public
account so who the [ __ ] is telling you
that you're not beautiful it's not us
Yeah right it's not the people that
matter in your life that are telling you
that that's that's something that you're
struggling with yourself and the thing
about that is and I always mention that
the hardest part about fitness is people
being honest with themselves it's like
if you don't like the way you look then
you have the ability to change it but if
you keep trying to convince yourself
that you're happy with the way that you
are when you're not that's where it's
gonna mentally [ __ ] you up yeah and I
keep seeing these posts constantly and
it's just this long diatribe you see on
Instagram and everybody sees that [ __ ]
right and no one's gonna read it yeah
absolutely not you read the first three
sentences maybe then you get the gist of
it yeah but do you feel like anybody
kind of looked down on you after you
lost a lot of weight no I think a lot of
people got inspired to lose weight
themselves which is great no one's like
I miss the fat David oh I missed the fat
David too though sometimes that David
was pretty [ __ ] cool man it's just
fat David was dying and you note that
David was daeyang see that's the thing
that people don't think about as well is
that they don't think about the
consequences of their health yeah and it
just seems so far away that they're just
not worried about it but it's really sad
that it takes a lot of people something
like a traumatic event in their lifetime
yeah or they're like well kind of change
now yeah you know cuz they don't think
and I'm guilty of this as well like you
don't think that's gonna be you until
happens to you yeah and and sometimes
too even when something terrible happens
to them I mean because it's such a
mental thing if you go the opposite way
they just be like well [ __ ] it this is
this is this is my life you know that's
gonna be me forever
yeah you know and they're not trying to
better themselves and it's it's it's
almost easier for you to say [ __ ] it
well this is that yeah and this is who I
am this is what it's gonna be
for me I would almost be okay with
somebody understanding the the concept
of being big is unhealthy and they're
just gonna be like this is how I want to
live my life then cool that would be
easier for me to handle then me having
to sit around and have a conversation
with somebody and keep telling me they
keep telling me that I'm healthy I'm
healthy I was like yeah that's that's
that's rough because not only especially
if they have a platform yeah and it
enables other people to kind of feel
that yeah and and they keep convoluting
the concept of being healthy and happy
right so they keep trying to attach this
this unhealthy lifestyle as saying oh
I'm fit and I'm also a hundred pounds
overweight
yeah like that's where it becomes
something where i-i've never ever said
that you know even as a big guy I had I
had you know my friends know this - my
self-esteem was perfectly fine like I
felt I loved myself consistently
throughout being a big guy my whole life
but what did you tell me when you first
started training to me you were telling
me that you didn't even know you were a
fat guy yeah I didn't always thought
other people were like oh man that guy's
fat yeah and then it took Mariel to say
oh like like you're a fat person yeah
and that's the biggest problem with with
a lot of this issue is that people don't
associate these symptoms that they're
going through every day and they're not
associating that with bad health yeah
like we were talking about how people
are like oh yeah I have diarrhea every
day yeah and when it's diary everyday
it's just called poop straight up it's
and your poops aren't supposed to be
that way and that is a sign of poor gut
health or poor digestive health or list
goes on and on of all these potential
symptoms and these are red flags that
people don't think about yeah you know
you falling asleep at like 2:00 p.m.
after you eat lunch this is that sign
it's a bad sign it's not support like
and you don't have to be a big guy to go
through that yeah like I was going
through that too until I hired my own
coaches to keep me accountable
for whatever I'm doing and as soon as
they started changing all that for me
and as soon as they they kind of showed
me the like like yeah you need to be
more conscious of what you're eating
because to me when I'm eating I'm just
eating a lot of times and this happens
to everybody most of the time yeah is
that what you're just eating just eating
and then you know you're distracting
you're on your phone you're you're
watching TV you're doing work whatever
but you're not connecting to the food
and then you're not associating these
feelings that you have after you eat
yeah
or during your eating and then it
becomes a bigger issue food is highly
addictive and that's the thing I
couldn't really like wrap my head around
yeah you know because I I just thought
you know everybody has to you I can't
not eat yeah and the the problem with
the way that I was thinking was number
one I couldn't tell when I was full
number two I couldn't tell when I was
just completely satiated yeah and